welcome back to las vegas now summer is
the time to explore different flavors
and foods and we are learning just the
recipe from jeff jackson with smith's
food and drug the sponsors of this
segment
hello everybody i'm chef jeff from
smith's today's recipe is a corn and
zucchini fritter with a basil aioli the
reason i love this recipe is because i
can feed four to six people in under ten
dollars which is awesome nice and even
in today's
situation
that makes it even more better and you
were here to kind of talk about that a
little bit right right so that's awesome
that we can make a full meal for four to
six family members under ten dollars
we've all been hearing this ugly word of
inflation but at smith we want to help
share some tips and tricks just on how
you can save at the register so
everything that you see chef jeff
cooking with today is all part of our
brands meaning it's a smith's brand and
those are everyday low prices but really
have quality product and it's not just
when you see kroger on that brand it's
when you see simple truth organic
private selection so many great brands
that i have really come to love all
throughout the store yeah right so as we
are making this and chef justice what
did you mix here so what i did is i have
some fresh zucchini and then some fresh
corn seasonality is a big part of it too
buying things in season helps you save
money plus the quality of ingredients
are better so we have seasonal cells
actually that may keep items as
low for about eight weeks even so keep
out for those seasonal items and it's
crazy what a game changer this phone is
download the smith's app you can do all
of your shopping right on the app but
the best part is we have weekly digital
downloads to save you all of the money i
just looked at the digital downloads you
could earn up to 500 fuel points with
one of the coupons right now that makes
a huge difference so use that rewards
card right we're all looking to save at
the pump and our smith's rewards card is
another way to do that you can save as
much as a dollar five just just from
your rewards card but even better if you
use the rewards mastercard that smith
offers you can get a dollar 25 off off
of a gallon at the pump up to 35 gallons
too so you're you're saving
about forty dollars if you use that hole
right
i am making sure that i'm never too far
from low to make sure that i can get my
fuel at smith's to be honest i might be
a little biased but if i'm going to save
a buck 05 i'm doing it so what i did
here is just mix all of the ingredients
here to make an aioli is that right yes
an aioli is basically a mayonnaise base
a flavored mayonnaise really and so
you've got that done awesome work by the
way thank you and so what i did is i got
all of my fritter stuff mixed together i
got it in some oil at 350 degrees
it's cooking away and basically you just
want to go about three to five minutes
on either side until they are golden
brown
so we'll go ahead and let those cook
okay so these cook for about
i'd say about four to five minutes to
lose my thermometer get them out of the
oil let them drain on some paper towels
and you've got these delicious zucchini
and corn uh fritters and you've got this
awesome aioli that you made best part
about these is they're cheap and of
course you can get all these ingredients
your local smiths thanks for all those
tips that you gave us today for saving
money that's great
all right so we will see you all next
time bye everyone
thank you again to smith's food and drug
for sponsoring this segment for more
information visit the website on your
screen las vegas now will be